[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants nous sommes ravis de
vous retrouver ce soir après notre long
voyage en écosse heulot et nounours est
impatient de vous montrer les surprises
qui n'a rapporté pour vous it is aux
magnifiques surprises
fermez les yeux et ouvrez toutes grandes
les petites oreilles
quant à nicolas call raf on dirait un
musicien dans la rue on me lance une
belle pièce doré ainsi que tu veux
m'acheter
mosley musiciens ambulants ont te voilà
en fait revenu
global
au bon
qu'est-ce que tu nouvelles apportées ou
mal
bosse mâles barre
des 10 non mon sac de voyage
en anglais c'est mon bac
c'est encore par les français au moment
où ton ku
qui libérera
montrer
plus
lui voilà un splendide de culte pour
nicolas
[Musique]
voyons nicolas les hommes et les dons en
écosse world tous
indiqué
[Musique]
sarah l'onu
moi je suis un gars au domaine et voici
un jeu fort
prenant l'eau
[Musique]
c'est un motel use un pantalon pour
faire du cheval
c'est trop fort mentalement pour une
fille et
puis c'est tout ce que tu nous auras
portés aux noms nounou et lili mais deux
gentils petits amis écossais monte au
nez pont fut un
délicieux ou d'y
apporter mois plats
qu'ils sont gentils sottise est passé
merci aux preneurs qu'il est vous êtes
vous dit
tu leur diras qu'on va le manger avec
papa et maman
tu es très gentil mon petit nicolas je
pète gentil ne doit alors m'importune
jus
peut-être qu'elle n'irait cette jupe si
tu la veux la donne et bien moi
c'est un pantalon de garçons à la scie à
l'eau les enfants ou dodo
ce que je suis content merci petite
soeur
bravo vous avez trouvé la bonne solution
à long
ou d'hommes
moun nan
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ollon nounours dépêche-toi me voilà
brosse là tu sco bonne nuit les enfants
fait beau rêve
adobe
[Musique]